paralysé avec l' annonce du premier
confinement le sport est pourtant restée
au coeur des centres d'intérêts
cloisonné chez eux de nombreuses
yvelinois ont pratiqué la course à pied
la musculation le fitness certains même
se sont lancés deux plus grands défis
comme courir un marathon dans leur
jardin pour les sports en club
déconfinement n'aura pas empêché l'arrêt
des saisons annoncé le 25 mai 2020 un
soulagement pour certains une
frustration pour d'autres qui n'iront
pas au bout de leur objectif
une semaine avant on était deuxième on a
perdu le dernier match qui en fait nous
nous conduire à nous laisse en fait on
nationale 2 pour la saison prochaine car
les compétitions où était à compter du
12 mars ont été complètement interrompue
et on a comme on dit repris le solde à
ce moment là donc ça a été un peu
surprenant les saisons en cours du sport
amateur ont été annulés aux raccourcis
avec l'espoir de reprendre normalement
septembre une fois l'été passé pour les
professionnels certains événements
majeurs ont été décalées comme le tour
de france dont la dernière étape est
parti de mantes la jolie le 21 septembre
2020 on avait été frustré de pas avoir
de vélo pendant la période du gros
navires us deux res
et du coup événement donc un grand
plaisir tant plaisir de l événement
comme ça je le voulais cette année l
événement comme un bon
un beau symbole pour nous d'être ici
aujourd'hui mais les réjouissances sont
de courte durée avec la seconde vague de
l'épidémie et l'instauration du
couvre-feu à 21h les clubs sont obligés
de se réorganiser pas de vestiaires pas
de contact le respect obligatoire des
gestes barrières
le 2 novembre le couperet tombe le sport
est de nouveau à l'arrêt après
l'annnonce du second confinement des
centaines de sportifs de haut niveau
sont cependant sélectionnés pour pouvoir
continuer de s'entraîner pendant le
premier confinement du mois de mars en
fait les enfants ont continué à faire du
travail physique chez eux
mais malgré tout ils ont quand même
beaucoup perdu et on a mis du temps à
retrouver un niveau correct donc la
halle avantage c'est que les
entraînements se poursuivent donc il ya
moins de pertes
une fois n'est pas coutume le
déconfinement permet ensuite au club de
reprendre les entraînements en janvier
2021 des horaires aménagés étant donné
le couvre-feu donné à 18h ainsi que le
respect du protocole sanitaire un moyen
de se retrouver entre coéquipiers à
l'image du club de football de jouy en
josas
le groupe l'ambiance tout ça ça manque
ça manque beaucoup on va devoir les amis
tout est fermé et donc forcément de se
retrouver comme ça le dimanche c'est top
ça fait du bien déjà de retrouver les
copains de retrouver l'esprit d'équipé
faire un petit peu d'activités physiques
et sportives en collectivité parce que
faire tout seul pendant confinement
s'est pas forcément très agréable
alors que nous nous rappelons
aujourd'hui le premier anniversaire de
ce qui bouscule à la pratique de toute
activité de tout événement groupe et en
communauté le sport comme la culture ou
les loisirs reste un an plus tard dans
la tente de pouvoir reprendre
normalement
la fédération de rugby a déjà fait le
choix d'annuler les saisons en cours
pour les amateurs d'autres sports se
joindront probablement bientôt à cette
décision